[Música]
segundo bloque económico de nuestra
mañana en directo américa resultado con
nosotros jorge hablemos del déficit
comercial en eeuu bueno la cifra que hay
un 19,1 por ciento en abril con respecto
al mes anterior hasta ubicarse en los 87
mil 100 millones de dólares datos de la
oficina de análisis económicos mostraron
que en abril las importaciones bajaron
un 3,4 por ciento respecto a marzo y se
situaron en los 339 mil 700 millones de
dólares mientras que las exportaciones
aumentaron un 3,5 por ciento hasta los
252 mil 600 millones de dólares las
cifras sugieren ahora que el comercio
podría contribuir al crecimiento
económico este trimestre por primera vez
en dos años el déficit comercial raúl es
la diferencia negativa entre lo que un
país vende al exterior o sea las
exportaciones y lo que ese mismo país
compra a otros países o lo que se conoce
también como las importaciones se
produce el déficit cuando un país
importa mayores bienes y servicios de
los que es capaz de vender al exterior
bueno sobre cambiamos ahora información
porque en rusia el presidente de la amm
y putting ordenó que elaboren medidas
para impulsar el crecimiento bueno
también dijo que a lo russia controlar
la inflación rusia suspendió una norma
presupuestaria en virtud de la cual que
analizaba los ingresos extra el petróleo
y el gas hacia el fondo de la riqueza
nacional durante la pandemia el
ministerio de finanzas prevé restablecer
la norma en virtud de la cual también
compraba divisas pero decidió no hacerlo
tras la imposición de las sanciones
occidentales que han impedido a moscú
acceder a cerca de la mitad de sus
reservas de oro y divisas ahora en lugar
de aumentar el fondo de riqueza natural
los ingresos adicionales del petróleo y
el gas pueden gastarse en cualquier
propósito que el gobierno elija putin no
dijo detalles de las nuevas normas pero
aseguró que los préstamos corporativos e
hipotecarios necesitaban un impulso
económico jorge lemos volvió a amenazar
con dejar el acuerdo de compra de
twitter bueno como recordaremos moscú
acusa a twitter de negarse a
proporcionar los datos sobre el número
de cuentas falsas que operan en el sitio
los analistas dicen que podría tratarse
de una estrategia para intentar salirse
de este acuerdo de compra desde que
hemos empezó a plantear la compra las
acciones de twitter han caído más de un
20 por ciento en el último mes veamos
y los modos lo ha hecho oficial después
de que sus abogados presentarán una
carta acusando a twitter de frustrar
activamente sus solicitudes de más
información
el ceo de tesla vuelve a amenazar con
abandonar su oferta de 44 mil millones
de dólares para comprar twitter si no
consigue la información que quiere su
petición conocer la cantidad de spam y
cuentas falsas que operan en la
plataforma estas cuentas conocidas como
bots se gestionan a menudo de forma
anónima y mediante inteligencia
artificial interactuando con los tweets
y difundiendo información errónea
twitter es consciente del problema y en
sus declaraciones al gobierno estima que
alrededor del 5 por ciento de sus 229
millones de cuentas son spam sin embargo
nos cree que las cifras mucho mayor y en
mayo tuiteó que al menos el 20 por
ciento son falsas
el multimillonario afirma que la
metodología de las pruebas de twitter es
poco rigurosa y que quiere realizar sus
propios análisis lo que requiere
información adicional que la plataforma
aún no ha facilitado hubiera respondido
diciendo que ha compartido todos los
datos relevantes y que tiene la
intención de la transacción y hacer
cumplir el acuerdo de fusión al precio y
los términos acordados desde que hemos
que empezó a hablar sobre las cuentas de
spam el mes pasado las acciones de
twitter han caído un 20% lo que ha
provocado una demanda de los accionistas
que acusan a moscú de desinflar el
precio de las acciones los analistas
dicen que moscú podría estar buscando
renegociar los términos del acuerdo o
desecharlo por completo pero si se aleja
podría enfrentarse a una cuota de
ruptura de mil millones de dólares
pobre como siempre gracias por toda la
información económica nos vemos mañana
con más economía aquí en directo américa
nosotros nos vamos directo hasta parís
[Música]